here you go Sabrina your buckwheat cake
with coconut butter almonds and nuts
strawberries and rhubarb sugar-free with
pistachios gluten-free no milk
derivatives enjoy your meal
nowadays eating isn't that simple
anymore wherever we go we are told to
eat certain foods and not others we are
told we eat too much some food is bad
for us some aren't ethical their
production and consumption are bad for
the environment we must worry about what
we eat as it's full of preservatives and
pesticides and that we should become
vegan that it would be better if we
eliminated gluten meat fish eggs sugars
milk and all processed food all this
creates a widespread fear and confusion
on our tables between truth
pseudoscience Miracle diets and new
dogmas that questions the traditional
way we feed ourselves many worried
people are seeking Solutions through
alternative and curious diets
I eat therefore I am
such a lovely surprise to find vegan
vegetarian and gluten-free dishes
let's say that we are very careful about
what intolerances and allergies might be
various way of eating so we must be up
to date on everything
they listed allergies too have you seen
there you find the 14 major allergies
included in the menu so you already see
what you may or not choose of course
bread is gluten free buckwheat bread and
two black rice crackers
it's not easy today to run a restaurant
there are many people like Sabrina that
go through the menu searching for
ingredients they absolutely want to
avoid like gluten lactose but not only
sure
as a main course we have eggplants and
spinach beets sauteed with parsley
I'm much happier now and even feel free
to go out to lunch as finally there is
more awareness towards people with food
intolerances but also towards the
quality of food in general and compared
to the past now it's a pleasure to dine
out
Sabrina is 54 and has been testing for
quite a while the reactions her body has
to certain food
since childhood the taste of meat has
always very much bothered me but also by
its smell since I was a child I must say
my mother as a good Lumber made me try
all kinds of meat so I know exactly what
I'm missing out on and what I dislike
growing up as a personal choice cruelty
on animals Define my definitive choice
to become a vegetarian
foreign
my choice of not getting completely rid
of gluten but being very careful about
it is based on physical well-being the
problem started when I noticed that my
abdomen had swollen which didn't mean I
was silic or that I was suffering from
intolerances I did exams for that but
mostly a reaction to some kind of grains
that aren't the ones of the past healthy
ones we have back in the days and that's
why I had these reactions I feel much
better metabolically less weight less
tired and fatigued
tanka
my doctor knows about my food
preferences and my blood exams are good
with no particular deficiencies
I also avoid corn wheat I eat very
little rye and barley because even if
they do contain gluten it's a much more
digestible one since I started eating
those I don't have metabolic problems
any longer and my stomach doesn't swell
anymore while all the others that
contain no gluten at all like oats
aromat buckwheat and rice I consume
those regularly
I prefer not to eat processed food where
they sell gluten-free turnovers I prefer
to make them myself I give myself a
little time it's not so time consuming
and complicated
[Music]
our lives are too frenetic there is the
time to do stuff it just takes 15 to 20
minutes the time to make good pasta
so gluten-free works
gluten-free forever
for breakfast proteins oats and peanut
butter always
proteins carbs and fats it's a full meal
I digest it fast
I refilter oats if I take away the part
that remains more solid I bloat less
Breakfast of Champions
some people have decided to eliminate
some food elements from their diet
others have created a customized diet
Mikhail is 24 and is an athlete the
meals that he prepares and eat
methodically spells out his days from
the morning to late at night that race
is from last night at 2AM I couldn't
finish it at all it will be today's
entree
now I'm preparing chicken I'll season it
I will pull out the rice later
carrots and fennel as vegetables are
important usually I start at 9am by
preparing breakfast as soon as I get up
I eat at 10 30 and then eat again at 13
30 to 14.
depending on how many carbs I'm eating
because if I am I'm sure I'll be hungry
much sooner than that
but if I had a normal meal I can't
resist about three hours
and so on up to eight to ten meals a day
the meals are actually Four with four
more snacks at least I prefer to cook
once every day and a half instead of
cooking all the time and stressing out
about it eating shouldn't be a stress
maybe now I'll have three slices one way
and three in another so I don't get
tired of it during the day and have
different flavors
given that I eat just rice chicken eggs
carrots and other few things I must very
taste to keep my appetite stimulated my
friends tell me I'm obsessed that I'm
insane
this is the most reoccurring adjective
but in the end they all come and ask me
for advice so I probably am not that
insane
if I eat anything different from my
usual diet I can immediately feel a
difference in my stomach that I can't
quite explain it's like a weight an
immediate bloating
precisely one kilogram now I'll divide
it up so I can know how more or less how
much I eat each time about 100 grams I
draw lines just to not use a scale so I
don't stress out about it
foreign
I prefer to cut up the chicken and mix
it in with all the rest so it becomes a
single course it's not very nice to see
but it's practical
I never eat raw stuff I prefer to cook
everything I could eat carrots in my
salad for example or fennel but I don't
like raw vegetables and absolutely not
meat
I could never go back even if I wanted
it would be a problem to start eating at
someone's house again when I'm invited
to lunch I always eat everything I like
everything but when food is too seasoned
there is too much oil or some uncooked
butter it bothers me and weighs me down
a repetitive diet that would annoy
others before Mikhail it's the only
possible one
I think I'll keep eating this way now
I'd say I eat this way forever because
it makes me feel great actually I feel
great since I started eating this way I
felt well before too but a different
kind of feeling I wasn't as weird as I
am now even if I had always eaten
healthy food my mother and father always
cook good things in the past it was a
fake well-being because I was used to
those circumstances so you don't really
know how you'd possibly feel how
energetic eating the right food feel
full of life basically when you eat well
you're full of Energies
what was it about half a kilogram of
rice no it was like 100 grams only what
is it the best for me that grows and
grows exactly overcooked maybe with a
little more water than usual
I make a point of eating just pigs
horses cows I just eat animals that
weigh more than myself but I can see you
being a vegan just once a week I'd give
it a try
foreign
44 years ago after time spent between
Lisbon and London decided to move to
tasinio with his family in pursuit of a
better quality of life
I grew up with a Mediterranean diet the
one we call Mediterranean 40 years ago
meaning that 40 years ago we thought
margarine was healthy then we found out
it's worse compared to butter in any
case it was a strictly Omniverse
nutrition where at the maximum opposite
extreme we arrived in London and ate
frozen pizza and Hagen does every day
then we started research in asking
ourselves how we could live longer and
healthier and what kind of diet we
choose for our children in that case so
we approached veganism
not just vegan actually raw vegans they
cook nothing of what they eat
raw food is living food because in the
process of keeping food fresh that is by
not cooking all nutritional values are
kept alive they haven't been cooked
I was thinking about making the dried
cabbage leaves as you asked and started
making the burger you should put the
sunflower in water
aqua
we use selected types of cooking that
are generally not considered cooking we
try food temperature never goes about 42
degrees in a ventilated area as if they
were dried in the Sun or we ferment by
pickling and other food alterations but
not cooking
especially for their son Leonardo that
they chose Raw veganism
we thought it would be better for our
son to eat healthy food
also because we were getting worried of
all the additives animals are fed to to
grow so fast
to arrive on our tables full of
unhealthy products hormones pesticides
noise but you see that and so we decided
that it was better to eat all that is
closer to Nature
[Music]
Leonardo is mostly vegan not raw vegan
it doesn't worry us much if he will or
will not become raw vegan what we care
about is to feed him the healthiest food
this is an almonds and coconut pie and
here we have chocolate strawberry orange
the cream is made from cashews and fruit
okay very Taste of the coconut yes
if you could only find Meats in the past
cheeses and traditional produce
nowadaysona markets vegan and raw vegan
Specialties can be found as well showing
many is a big curiosity about these
nutritional fats
[Music]
with a raw diet you feel the effects
immediately which can be lightness and
satiated at the same time you don't feel
tired and ready to sleep right after
eating you have more energy
majority energy
[Laughter]
since we started changing to vegan diet
we are almost never ill also Leonardo is
difficult he gets ill this is very
interesting as a lot of moms normally
say that when a child at the
kindergarten is ill all the kids are
home ill too Leonardo is always at
school because he's rarely ill
mulatto yes
we only eat biological food and eating
them raw we must be very careful to
avoid unnatural pesticides contamination
as much as we can
this is delicious have you had it
already
no it's the first time
right now the rub is very popular it's a
kind of bread loaf made with carrots and
flax seeds dried at 42 degrees they dry
for five to six hours then we fill them
with carrots apple vinegar beets
and cashew cheese raw cheese that is
salad leaves depending on the season we
add a bit of fennel or olives it depends
this is very popular right now
the dishes in the raw vegan diet can be
very simple but if a little more
elaborated it can take quite a few hours
of preparation
and Tatiana spent entire days on this
activity that is almost a mission for
them
I'm happy when people eat with us even
if it's just for once or twice a week
twice a month to try our food I'm happy
they can eat healthy be vegan for a
change and find out about raw food
[Music]
once you try you you want to have our
own wings
I believe everyone's mentality is
Shifting in 30 to 50 years there will be
many people eating vegan food
foreign
having always practiced a lot of sports
particularly biking even in my youth I
practice a lot of sports I was always
told that carbs are essential for
practicing sports for endurance
resistance basically it's the fuel the
carbs are fuel and I have always eaten
them for example fruit bread cereal for
breakfast
a plate of pasta always whole wheat
pasta but nonetheless pasta then a piece
of cake adds dessert and for dinner yes
proteins meat or fish or vegetable
protein lentils or chickpeas
chechi
is an elite athlete since early age
journalist for Fallon Antonio Ferretti
has recently discovered that some of his
nutrition rules that he had been living
by for years were not suitable for his
lifestyle any longer and so it was
required he changed some habits I'm
almost 62 and especially in the last
three to four years I noticed I was
losing muscle tone but we call lean body
mass I've always been quite skinny but I
was losing actual muscle even biking
every day even for long circuits I also
enjoy cross-country skiing but
nonetheless I kept noticing muscles even
those in my legs were losing definition
then I met with various nutritionists
and all of them insisted on the fact
that especially at a certain age it's
important to eat proteins pretty much at
every meal so starting from breakfast
lunch there should always be a protein
especially animal proteins animals
breakfast proteins are usually quills
eggs I eat five and a piece of guaca and
some almonds then I have some fruit and
sometimes a slice or two of bread
because egg have the best taste a little
Aroma to them a bit spicy it's a
pleasure to eat them I then heard from a
nutritionist that grows eggs according
to him have a lighter impact on
cholesterol especially if eaten in the
morning I haven't actually verified it
but they are part of this diet and it's
a pleasure to eat them
foreign
with this change this change in my diet
after a few months I was feeling much
better again I could actually feel my
muscles again even in my legs they
filled my pants better I mean I eat a
lot of meat but also a lot of vegetables
raw vegetables cooked in the evening I
say that the largest part is made up
from vegetables also because they
explained to me that the balance to
maintain in this diet the acid and the
basic parts of the nutrition so these
last two years I feel almost younger way
giving up animal proteins in the course
of time can have consequences
deficiencies especially I must say that
during my cyclist career when I was a
pro I had been attracted let's say
caught up in this kind of macrobiotic
diet very whole meal with little meat
for a period of time when I was racing
practicing four or five hours a day I
tried to eat just whole meals with no
meat at all and I almost became anemic
in fact I still carry some consequences
even now my iron and ferritin are always
at the limit now this is improving too
but giving up animal proteins can really
bring to consequences especially at my
age if you want to be still active and
in good shape is
she has made a very extreme choice in
what she chooses to eat by adopting a
diet described in a book by German
author Arnold arid who lived in escona
on Monte verita at the beginning of the
1900s
I become fruitarian six to seven years
ago purely by accident reading some
pages on the internet I kept seeing
suggestions about meat so I asked myself
as a matter of fact I eat very low meat
also not much fish but I was curious to
find out if they were healthy or not
then I decided to find out who Eric was
a doctor in the 18th century beginning
of the 1900s and he had started healing
people with a fruitarian diet at that
point I tried to understand what
happened in this case I told myself if
it heals means it does no damage so it
detoxes helps to live a longer and
healthier life and a spirit of happiness
foreign
I already was following a vegan diet I
had eliminated also cereals and eggs but
I still ate greens so I started this
journey not as an immediate change but
slowly eliminating pasta bread all the
cereals and it's been the greatest
discovery of my life I really did
consume a large quantity I acquired a
lightness and vitality that I don't have
before
after a period without them you don't
feel the need for them any longer
at the beginning everyone was kind of
worried as I lost a whole lot of weight
but as Eric says first you dissolve your
body then you acquire it again even my
muscles dissolved as they were polluted
too so they had to be created over again
that's exactly what happened all Eric
says happened to me too I lost a whole
lot of weight and then I recovered it
all just like before
thank you
plans gift us with their fruits that's
why us fruitarians eat also vegetable
fruits the vegetable fruits we consume
are all those fruits that contain seeds
eggplants tomatoes peppers zucchini
cucumbers
Etc also olives and avocados that are
fruits containing fats because we need
it to live
is
don't eat those vegetables that are only
leafy like spinach cabbage cauliflowers
or artichokes broccoli asparagus fennel
those are plants that want to live and
then tubers like potatoes those are full
of starch we don't eat them
my breakfast starts with an apple
and there are also Apple Italians they
just eat apples that could be
problematic to relate with others I live
relating to others and it's already hard
to dine out as it is if I start eating
apples only everyone will start avoiding
me and throwing apples at me
face
the real reasons of the fruitarian
revolutions are mostly ethical
humans are evolving so are also
understanding what is better for
themselves and the environment they live
in respecting everyone the thing is not
only Health but respect for themselves
and all living creatures so living
creatures include animals and plants too
that's the most important thing
lorenza is not alone in this choice and
to demonstrate it she is bringing us to
discover the first vegan fruitarian
restaurant in Italy
this is a fruitarian pizza made with
plantain which is a green banana cooked
in the oven and then processed on top we
have raw veggies
[Music]
it's the one and only foodarian
restaurant in Italy there is a need to
offer and encourage people to think
about a way of eating that is not
specific to our species meaning it's not
natural to the human race
the experience that he acquired during
the years while making traditional
dishes has then brought the chef
Fernando Bruno to suggest a Cuisine that
he feels closer to himself
being a vegan first and consequently a
fruitarian I decided to offer in my
restaurant an alternative Cuisine
compared to the classic standards of
Cuisine that uses animals or animal
derivatives because us Italians we have
a great tradition of Vegetarian Cuisine
in every regionately
this is a fruitarian tartar made with
only fruit it's made with Jackfruit an
exotic fruit that is treated and
processed with sun-dried tomatoes
some fruits are extraordinary just take
a classic squash put it in the oven for
about 20 minutes not at a very high
temperature let's say around 150 degrees
the squash is cooked and we can make the
pulp into a cream which can be used for
different preparations for example a
tasty plate of organic fettuccine with
squash pulp and organic sun-dried
tomatoes is very appreciated by
fruitarians
[Music]
The Season's fruit and vegetables but
also ingredients that come from afar
I discovered the ductile plentine with
which I can make first courses too or
even a pizza that has nothing less going
for it than the classic flower Pizza
well it's definitely healthier because
it's a fruit pizza
plantian is cooked in the oven when it's
black you peel it and then blend it at
high speed then you can season it with
extra virgin olive oil the kind without
stones a pinch of pink Himalayan salt
and then work it like it or pizza dough
same for bread you might want to make
canopies or pastries
amongst the clients some Curious folk
and many converts
quality of food like meat or tuna fish
is poor has become more toxic fish is
full of heavy metals Etc so apart from
the whole vegan debate we need to
consider the quality of food that is not
the same as in the past
food is high energy food nutritious it
charges you as it has a very high
vibrations it's just been pickled and
not treated
and it's so marvelous to see such
colorful Plates Full of Life and real
ISM protein diet is for everyone of
course it takes some patience patience
to cook we should look back at the past
and ReDiscover what our mothers used to
cook all the time they spend cooking
those marvelous meals
[Music]
my breakfast starts at 5 30 a.m it lasts
about half an hour I weigh everything
because knowing my caloric intake during
the whole day is essential to me as my
goal is to be in perfect shape my body
my appearance is my business cards
thank you
Simone Simone is a personal trainer he's
44 and eating is to him much more than
just feeding himself he is always
refraining from the pleasures of good
food in order to maintain fit and for a
personal research on the best possible
diet to follow
my diet is mostly natural full of greens
I follow the five servings at least five
meals a day I have my snacks which are
mostly a fruit according to the fruit
that is in season my lunch is mostly
protein so vegetables and some proteins
while I prefer to move carbs to dinner
time to reconcile sleep
I made food and education My Lifestyle
because we are what we eat and therefore
by eating junk food as I like to say our
body would be similar to a garbage bin
because
caring about nutrition is essential for
people like Simone who competes in
bodybuilding contests I've tried
numerous diets mostly because I like to
experiment for work to be able to advise
others which diet would be best suit the
person's lifestyle
but also out of curiosity to see the
actual Effectiveness it has
I also followed the paleo diet for a
while it was well known in my
environment so many proteins and very
small carb quantities obviously
accompanied by fruit and vegetables
I tried the hunting pig out a hunter's
diet where you eat a huge amount the
Peril diet linked to the alkalinity of
the food the Zone diet but just for a
short period it was too complex to
follow I tried the blood type diet the
Warriors diet
[Music]
nowadays I follow a nutrition richer in
carbs up to 60 65 on 3 000 calories so a
very large amount of carbs
precisely because he has tried on
himself so many Alternatives he knows
the strength and weaknesses of them all
as a general rule those who decide to go
vegan do it mostly for Consciousness
issues if a person one of my pupils
decides for it I advise them to have a
nutritionist follow them
there have been problems especially with
people that have eliminated carbs
their muscle mass is eaten away making
it harder to reconstruct a muscle tone
because as soon as you give them a
little more calories they tend to put on
weight and they don't want that to
happen
people need to find their balance in
nutrition as we all have our own
personal relationship with food with my
job I try to help people find their own
balance which doesn't have to be my own
mine is strictly tied to my job to the
competitions others they have other
necessities
foreign
[Music]
nowadays there are many food fats once
people turn vegan once raw vegans and
Celiac even if they aren't actually
Celiac there is a bit of everything even
I as a young girl tried many kinds of
diets as I wanted to see what would work
out for me and it seems to me the best
experience is the one we try on
ourselves it's true there were times I
was single-minded about 20 to 30 years
ago and I ate mostly raw and believed
the science behind raw nutrition and I
actually did have the benefits
of course when I became a nutritionist I
understood how well you can feel how
much better feeling free and eating a
very varied diet and all the unique
benefits it can bring to health
it's important for nutritional experts
like barbarnaldi to warn the general
public of the joys and dangers of any
diet
there are a few famous American stars
that follow the vegan diet for instance
right now there is a boom of this diet
but thinking about when I was 20 30
years old there were already was the
boom of the vegan and microbiotic diets
these are waves like waves as trends
that usually have nothing to do with the
real instincts of a person
clearly there are also new kinds of
obsessions fixations for example
orthorexia named by an American
physician a few years ago
it's not a term that is accepted by
general medicine yet but it's a term
used to describe those that are totally
obsessed with healthy food everything
must be organic healthy air has to be
pure water must be pure and distilled no
coffee sleeping early not smoking no
alcohol no getting upset
I've seen people this way I have
patients that without my approval would
never have a square of chocolate for
snack they are so scared of a square of
chocolate that could be harmful well I
try my best to erase Their Fear of food
with my patience I do the opposite
explaining that we have instincts also
of course things that don't grow in
nature that we enjoy them because we
were brought up with those tastes hence
if we have little quantities of those
things without fear we can benefit from
them fulfilling a mental desire or a
heartfelt one of that slice of cake
small piece of cheese without
exaggerating and freeing ourselves from
these obsessions
sat soon